come on unfinished business this is kind
of a badass title it's like something a
fella would say like we have unfinished
business now to get him laughed out of
the room like even like the shitty Vince
Vaughn movie do you really though like
shut up so unfinished business stars
Vince Vaughn
Dave Franco and Tom Wilkinson and Vince
Vaughn owns a company buy owns a company
I mean he owns a really small company
and wishes only two employees are hey
Franco and Tom Wilkinson he goes to
Europe he goes to Germany to close this
deal cuz he really needs to close this
deal and that's the movie you're looking
for a more refined point the movie
didn't have one so I can't give you one
but first of all yeah Vince Vaughn plays
the same thing and everything he's not
even the problem in this movie it would
have been safe to have another Vince
Vaughn comedy the movies just all over
the place you know you hear people
describe other movies all over the place
this is the epitome of that the
jokes didn't flow the scenes didn't flow
every joke was just like an easy joke
and most the funny parts in the trailer
are the funny ish parts in this movie
this is how I pick this apart I
look at the scene from the trailer as it
was presented the movie I think to
myself alright if that scene if that
punch line was pulled out of the movie
but the scene be any different in the
case for this movie not only would the
scene be no different whatsoever but the
scene would flow more it's almost like
they wrote this joke for the trailer and
they had a shoehorned it in the movie
somewhere and this is like the 13th
thing wrong with the movie fact is the
movie was boring as I should not be
bored this is a comedy I love to laugh
my favorite thing I go to those suave
ass Playboy Basterds and I'm like oh
yeah you get a lot of ass but do you
laugh as much as this guy no well who's
really happy so what tell myself anyway
nothing in this movie was funny the only
funny parts are Tom Wilkinson the funny
thing about him is he's an old guy
trying to act like a young dude he's
like doing the things that the young
guys are doing so sorry alright well
that's just innately funny-ish that's
not a credit to the writing it's just
human nature that that is just
easily funny Dave Frank Otte all right
you know I love the guy his character in
this movie is the biggest idiot I think
I've ever seen ever he makes Ralph
Wiggum look like Bradley Cooper and
limitless after he takes the pills
this dude is that
- but there's nothing endearing about it
there's nothing like oh it's got a
little brother is about it you want him
to go away
she'd never want the cast to go away
they wanted him to go away and I was
like well now that we're negotiating can
you all just go away can I get my money
back for this movie from the get-go in
this movie the first scene I knew there
was going to be a problem I knew the
pacing was just gonna be off I knew this
was gonna be a choppy ass movie because
the movie starts out Vince Vaughn is
arguing with his boss and you're like I
feel like there was a scene of setup
leading to this firing that's about to
happen or him walking out on his job no
he's just like it's like in the middle
of the argument there was no lead in the
middle so immediately you just kind of
feel like you're lost you're like wait
wait how did we get here what's the
conference all right I guess I'll take
your word for it you feel like that
person who came into the middle of two
people arguing and then they turn to you
and they're like right I mean am i right
you're like I don't have enough
information to assess that that's how
you feel but it's the movie so it just
keeps going you're like no you don't you
can't assess you need to go with Vince
Vaughn now and then to fill you in and
break down exactly what's gonna happen
in the course of this movie Vince Vaughn
immediately does the voice-over that he
did in the trailer to fill you in it
just doesn't stop there's mixed signals
like are you supposed to care about him
and his job are you supposed to be there
he's family problems Vince Vaughn's
trying to deal with his sons getting
bullied that's like the touching part of
the movie but it's so out of left field
you feel like that entire home dynamic
wasn't in this movie and someone was
like you know it needs a little more
heart in this movie right in the fact
that Vince Vaughn will have a son and
then he's just dealing with him being
bullied yeah that's perfect 90% of it
takes place over Skype so you feel like
the two actors never actually saw each
other until the end of the movie and
film it separately and boom you have a
whole other arc yeah before he left on
his trip there was a scene where he was
talking with this kid that led into the
whole bullying thing guys unfinished
business was a complete waste of money
worse than that it's a waste of time
I value my time you should too don't see
this movie if you have passes you're
like cabinets free no that's an
hour-and-a-half you're never going to
get back you do anything with it hour
and a half life is short spend an hour
and a half while because unfinished
business is
I think about movies like this when I
get out of the misery all right we had
Mordecai not too long ago would I rather
watch Mordechai or this hands down
really give me more dekat there you go
all right guys so unfinished business
have you seen it what did you think
about it but I read that comment below
let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more